الان نعود للتطورات الميدانيه وما يجري في
الخرطوم معلم منهم درمان مراسل الجزيره
على باقي اظافر عبد الباقي مرحبا بك معنا
والحديث عن اشتباكات باسلحه وصلت الى
الثقيله جنوبيه الخرطوم فما هي التطورات
والتحديثات الميدانيه اليوم
نحن في هذا الصباح وفي هذه اللحظات انا
الان استطيع ان اسمع تحليق طائره تتبع
لسلاح الجو السوداني واغلب الظن انها
طائره استطلاع ظلت في حاله تحليق مستمر
وكذلك هنالك اخبار سمعناها من مصادر وايضا
نستطيع ان نسمع اطلاق نار متقطعه في منطقه
الغربي وسط الخرطوم في منطقه شارع القابه
وهنالك معلومات اخرى عن اشتباكات الان في
منطقه الخرطوم منطقه شرق النيل اشتباكات
باسلحه ومختلفه وسماع لاطلاق اصوات مختلفه
للنار في هذه المنطقه بالامس كانت هنالك
معارك متسعه وربما تكون الاعنف من نوعها
من بعد انتهاء او توقف الهدن التي نتجد
عنها منبر جده الاشتباكات تركزت بشكل
اساسي في منطقه جنوب الخرطوم وصلت الى
مناطق لم تكن في السابق تصلها نحن نتحدث
عن اشتباكات بالقرب من سلاح المدرعات
وبالقرب من منطقه اليرموك العسكريه والقرب
ايضا منطقه مستودعات الغاز وهي منطقه
خطيره اذا ما وصلها القتال ستكون اثاره
كارثيه وبالفعل البارحه حدث حريق ولكن تم
السيطره عليه هذه المعارك ذات صله معارك
اخرى تدور منذ اسبوع حول معسكر طيبه جنوبي
الخرطوم وهو معسكر حصين لقوات الدفاع
لقوات الدعم السريع تحاول القوات المسلحه
الاطباق على هذا المعسكر من ثلاث اتجاهات
ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه لم يحدث انتصار
بين وواضح في معارك معسكر وطيبه حدثت كذلك
مع
محدود في مناطق ام درومان ومناطق الخرطوم
ايضا خارج الخرطوم ما زالت احتمالات
انفتاح القتال لمناطق اخرى مثل كت
والجنينه
هي احتمالات راجحه نعاني من صعوبات في
التواصل مع هذه الجهات لمعرفه ماذا يحدث
هنالك بازداد مدينه الجنينه التي رشح انها
تتعرض لمخاطر اكبر ليست مخاطر عسكريه فحسب
مخاطر بسبب اغلاق المشافي وانعدام الخدمات
حتى المياه الان منطقه تواجه الصعوبات في
الوصول لمصادر المياه وبعض المصادر تقول
انها محاطه بوجود عسكري كثيف للدعم السريع
وبعدد من القوات المناصره له ذات الطبيعه
القبليه منهم درمان مراسع الجزيره على
الباقيه الظافر شكرا لك